نعم تحياتي يا خالد في الحقيقه مدينه
خرسون الان تحت قبضه القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه داخل المدينه الان القوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه والاستخبارات والفرق
الاستطلاعيه لاقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
وعلى تخوم المدينه الكتائب من المشاه ومن
الالويه المختلفه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه سوكارونا قوات الدفاع
الاقليميه وغيرها طبعا ستدخل هذه الفرق
الى داخل المدينه بعد ان تنتهي القوات
الخاصه والفرق الاستطلاحيه من عمليه
الاستطلاع والبحث عن اي قوات روسيه داخل
المدينه بعد ذلك ستبدا الفرق المتخصصه في
عمليه نزع العلاقات
والبحث عن المتفجرات ثم بعد ذلك ستبدا
عمليه تعزيز الدفاعات داخل المدينه على
ضفه النهر اليمنى والتي الان تسيطر عليها
القوات المسلحه همم الاخرى طبعا القوات
الروسيه انسحبت الى الضفه
وعزز الدفاعاتها ولكن طبعا ايضا الان
الحديث يدور حول همم هذه الدفاعات على
القوات المسلحه ان تقوم بابعاد الاليات
العسكريه الثقيله والمدرعات عن الضفه
حوالي ما يقال الى 80 كيلومترا حتى لا
تكون في مرمى هيمارس او ناس مارس وهذه
الاسلحه التي تستطيع ان تصل الى هذا المدى
ايضا الحديث يدور عن ان الان المعركه
القادمه ستكون على الضفه الاخرى حيث ان
الرئيس قال انه لن يتركوا شبرا واحدا في
هذه الولايه ولا في كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وسوف يحاولون استعاده كامل
الاراضي الاخرانيه المعترف بها منذ العام
1901 طبعا هذه العمليه همم الهجوم المضاد
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه يتحدث عنها
القائد العام للجيش الاوكراني وقال ان هذه
العمليه لم تكن بادره حسني هي من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي وانما نتيجه لهجوم مضاد
قوي وعنيف وان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
استطاعت ان تضرب خطوط ال- القوات الروسيه
وان تقطع عليها القوه الطرق الاستراتيجيه
لذلك هي اجبرت على الانسحاب كما اجبرت على
الانسحاب من كيف ومن خارقه
ايضا حذيفه وباختصار
الى الخريطه سنجد ان الان بعد السيطره على
اخر سوني اذا استطعت القوات المسلحه عند
تسيطر على كامل سوف تتجه الى ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تعلن القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
عن اي عمليات في خرسون ولا القياده
السياسيه ولكن يتوقع المراقبون ان تكون
المعركه القادمه في ذلك لانها تربط ما بين
الدون باص وما بين الكريم